No surprise in the implementation.
We're subtracting step size times velocity times the estimate of the derivative
and that estimate stems from our central-difference formula.
In the residing diagram, you see that overall you achieved the right effect,
the sine curve is being shifted, but we definitely need to take care of the boundary--
at least when our signal reaches the boundary.
And let's try an experiment, I'm inserting the number 30 here,
meaning that I want to start off with 30 periods of the sine--not the single period of the sine.
And to make the image less clutter, let's use the number of 500 down here.
This is the result that we get--we can see the artifacts at the boundaries, which we already know,
which we already know, but there's a second phenomenon.
We can see that the amplitude is slightly growing.
We're growing from the blue curve to the green curve. So this looks unstable.
The higher the frequency that we fit in, the more unstable this becomes.
This is why I start with the sine wave and not with some rectangular function.
The good thing is if we combine this way of shifting the function with diffusion,
diffusion washes out the high frequencies and saves us from instability